insert intro here tick tocks
how different foods pass through my
intestines pasta
taco bell dairy
i guess someone's lactose intolerant a
single lettuce
beans
beans are good for your heart because
they have fiber
you thought i was gonna say something
else no actually everything goes through
your digestive system like this
because of peristalsis only people under
the age of 25 can hear this sound
so i shouldn't be able to hear it
considering i'm older than 25.
i will not say how much older i hear it
did you hear it yeah does that mean i'm
younger than 25
my ears are younger than 25. honestly
the most important thing you can do to
save your ears to hear stuff like this
not for this but for life is to not
listen to your headphones especially the
ones that are noise canceling or plug
your ears at more than 60
volume if you hang out to the 50 60
that's the safe zone for your ears
trust me on this
oh no don't be
[Music]
we don't operate with butter knives keep
it away from your mouth
a butter knife not so sharp scalpel on
your tongue no bueno
for a myriad of reasons
[Music]
our pole our pole made it into a
tick-tock
[Music]
meme game fire organ brain
pull fire no because i think there
should be an organ olympics like if
there was an olympics oh hey bear if
there was an olympics for something
bear would you participate in the oregon
olympics
bear i would never harvest your organs i
will not
ever harvest your kidneys
[Music]
six months ago i went on a journey to
transform my body that's what i've been
doing
you have to wake up every single day go
out and put the work in
you have to want it you're going to feel
the pain that's pretty good that's
exactly why
i haven't started this is my friend like
it's
funny got me i was about to give him
props and all that
and olig's a russian name so shout out
to my fellow ruski noga
espresso yes
is that miracle way
[Music]
pam no
i've said before that you are not a
chicken in a pot you are not a chicken
in a pot you are not a stove
but i wouldn't recommend doing that on
your skin it's going to make it all
sticky and clog your pores
trying to get some medical information
out to you
and i'm just struggling hard on this one
put you on something okay my boyfriend
is over i got a little hickey
a hickey is really just like a
superficial bruise this whoa
that's an aggressive hickey you're gonna
take a metal whisk
and you're gonna whisk your neck like
some freaking sunday morning eggs
i would just take a cold spoon and hold
it there like i would for any bruise
and it would also go away i mean
essentially what's happening here is
if it's a cold whisk better because it's
gonna shunt away some of that blood and
slow down the bruising by doing the
whisking you're actually breaking up
the the blood that's already there i
just wouldn't recommend it it's like not
a place that you should be whisking it's
not that serious
where's scarf turtlenecks turtlenecks
are cool
ask to rock okay guys i just found a
real life glitch and i have to know if
anyone else can see it
okay so you are gonna stare at this plus
sign in the middle of these two faces
and you're gonna focus all of your
energy
right there let your eyes rest and as
you are looking at this plus sign the
faces
on the left and right are going to start
to distort into some crazy alien looking
shapes and i have absolutely no idea
what's going on
what what is supposed to happen the
faces didn't seem strange to you
they did i just assumed that they were
strange faces watch your back and look
at the face oh really
as you are looking at this plus sign the
faces on the left and right are going to
start to distort
into some crazy alien looking
interesting i wonder why this happens
i think it has something to do with your
eyes focusing on a dark color and then
you're only paying attention to the
lighter colors of the faces and the way
that they're shaded there's something
happening here that i can't explain
quite well because i'm a family medicine
physician and i need some kind of
evolutionary biologist here to help me
with this one lifeline please
oh okay so i'm going to show you guys
something
okay let me know what you guys think
okay
[Music]
i used to be able to do that when i was
a kid and i would freak everybody out
yeah so she could suck in her abdomen
and
kind of push all her organs smush them
together
close open
bad songs to listen to
open open
i have a feeling that's not what happens
and he's playing a joke on us
i remember i met a really cool girl
angel uh at a conference and she was
showing me how her prosthetic arm worked
and i remember that it actually had
electrodes that connected to
her arm that allowed her to control some
of the fingers
and motions that it does i don't know if
this is the same model but it was a
funny clip nonetheless
he lost the weight in the trash can
[Music]
he's cutting his calories and watching
very specific
i like it that reminds me of the meme
with cut my carbs
oh that's good i actually have one in my
kitchen things that don't belong in your
body part
seven the image behind me is an x-ray of
someone's lower abdomen and pelvic area
and uh yeah is that a
goop jade egg because that's what i feel
like it is and recently they just got in
trouble for something with this
do not get your medical advice from goop
[Applause]
[Music]
someone has really good control of uh
their scapula also known as their
shoulder blade here
interesting something that we look for
in medicine known as scapular winging
where your scapula on one
side kind of sticks out almost like that
usually happens as a result of damage to
nerves or muscles in the area but i
don't know if that's what this patient
has or they just have hypermobility
of their scapula
i feel like this has a medical term
macro glossia i believe it's called
let's use a little google search here
macroglossia
yep macro glossy is a medical term for
an unusually large tongue
look at that it's like i went to med
school and all
now obviously because the tongue is in
your mouth and it can obstruct your
airway you can have problems with
breathing with sleep apnea
if god forbid you develop an
anaphylactic attack how much faster that
becomes a problem than the average
person is clear so you really have to be
monitored and tracked by
probably an ear nose and throat
specialist if i had a patient like this
i would ask them
to have an ent that they at least follow
up with on a regular basis so i have the
matagraphia which means whenever like i
touch my skin
it turns red and freaks out so like you
can see like i touch my face
i can write on my skin which is cool but
also it can be kind of
annoying yeah that's that's really
problematic especially because her skin
is so gentle that it happens that way
it's
literally happening to pressure and you
get like this histamine-induced response
i've never seen it to be so sensitive
that you touch and it happens that's
really unique
i have to look more into that throwback
to when men didn't know we had to peel
off layers of our skin after our period
i'm assuming this is has nothing to do
with the menstrual cycle
this is uh some kind of mask that
they're wearing i've done one of these
and it hurts to peel off ah it's a baby
what sunscreen do you use for him
i need some for my niece
um no vegans need sunscreen because
vegans are still human and have skin
especially babies shade is preferable to
sunscreen so if you're keeping your baby
in the shade that's okay this is uh
misinformation at its finest
mom i'm in the doctor's office i need
you to answer a few questions that i
don't remember
my favorite is when uh like a 17 year
old comes to the doctor and they're with
their parents and i ask
the patient the question of what's going
on what seems to be the problem and
right away the first thing they do is
look at the parent like wait i'm asking
you you can answer the question you're
here because you want to be here but it
happens every single time what is my
blood type
i put okay who asks for blood type
and he said okay do i have any prior
like incidents i don't remember having a
concussion
that probably has affected me my whole
life i'm trying to focus but my head
hurts probably from the concussion
what's their concussion or wasn't their
concussion i've never had a tetanus shot
no one has ever put the tetanus in me
deadness you understand that my blood
pressure's gonna be through the roof now
because you're making me so upset you're
making me so
this is like definitely inner monologue
for pretty much everyone that visits a
doctor's office
most people when they get a tetanus shot
they get a combined shot a tetanus
diphtheria
and acellular pertussis so they might
not know that it is a tetanus shot
my concussion is so strong right now
i feel like the word migraine has now
been replaced by the word concussion in
this skit
everybody say it's fake i do have a car
mode
like whoa look at me huh
what do you think about that i don't
have a collarbone
is this a visual trick i don't know i
don't can you can you live without a
collarbone i mean
yes it's not a vital organ i just don't
know how comfortable it would be and it
offers a layer of protection i'm going
to catalog this one
under tick tocks that need further
research
i like playing this game called how many
minutes
until i pass out
it's really fun
but like low-key i feel like
i've been in six of these at night i
feel like
it like slows my heart down no no
no no no no no no no no please do not do
this with
any medication any supplement do not
turn it into a game these have serious
side effects especially when it comes to
toxicity levels of supplements and
melatonin while
it is benign when you take it
appropriately if you take too much it's
no longer a benign substance
hi there i'm here to take my physician
licensing exam why are you smiling
what empty out your pockets that happens
all the time roll up your sleeves do you
have any cheat codes written on your
forearms
cheat codes up up down down patient left
right
when you come out here for your first
break i will state the phrase the yellow
eagle flies the farthest
and you will state in return but the
great heron flies further still
they do ask weird stuff when you walk
out of the room get one bathroom break
and you'll have 10 minutes there's only
a single stall bathroom for all 50 test
takers here today okay maybe i should go
before we start then better make it
quick we still have to do a retinal skin
and saliva dna confirmation they do do a
fingerprint what's interesting now is
it's all done virtually like my dad just
took his boards he's doing it from home
they literally make you have your webcam
on no one can walk behind you or
into the shot you have to while you sit
down record with your iphone
all four directions so they can see what
your testing environment's like it's
really secure
why i never wanted to take my bathroom
breaks here a bathroom break is 10
minutes right
but the process to walk out of the room
you have to sign out you have to get
fingerprinted and they have to ask you
some questions then to come back
you're waiting online while everyone
else is also waiting online and your
test timer starts running so you get
this crazy amount of anxiety so i was
like you know what i'll just hold it
thanks my bladder didn't say thanks
should you shower every day click here
to find out and as always stay happy and
[Music]
healthy